foreign
welcome to today's training where we
will be talking about YouTube channels
we're going to be talking about what are
YouTube channels how do you set them up
how do you optimize them and how do you
subscribe to them but before we start
let me quickly introduce myself I am
Mark campman I will be your digital
navigator for this video and if you
liked the video please click the like
button or if you want to join our
YouTube Community why don't you hit the
Subscribe button
so what's all this about in YouTube why
is YouTube so popular what makes it so
special and why do you need a YouTube
channel well the numbers they speak for
themselves over two and a half billion
people open YouTube at least once a
month that is one third of the world's
population
YouTube generates around 30 billion
dollars of Revenue in 2021 that is 78
million dollars a day these are
extraordinary amounts and this is
primarily advertising Revenue
now 25 of global mobile usage is for
YouTube it's one of the most popular
mobile apps and YouTube is the main
source of video for 78 of its users look
at the younger generation they don't
watch terrestrial TV they watch TV on
YouTube so on the back of this a whole
community of video creators have emerged
people who go on YouTube to present to
share to discuss to debate to invent to
compare and become famous with posting
their videos we call them YouTubers and
I don't have to mention people like
Gangnam Style Justin Bieber Shawn Mendes
Ariana Grande Dua Lipa and what about
brands that made it big on YouTube the
Dollar Shave Club Blendtec with blend
will it blend and it's the YouTube
channel they use as the social platform
for their videos a YouTube channel
serves as the home page for a user's
account anyone can view YouTube without
having an account however you need to
create a YouTube channel if you plan to
upload videos add comments or make
playlists but more about how to do this
later
businesses can also have a YouTube
channel these channels are different
from the personal channels because they
can have more than one owner of manager
so how do businesses benefit from
YouTube
well posting on YouTube will help people
find you on Google remember Google owns
YouTube by consistently utilizing
YouTube for your business you can
increase your chances of showing up in
the search results and improving your
own rankings
YouTube will also expose you to a huge
Global audience
YouTube is available in over 80
languages and it receives more than 30
million visitors a day who watch nearly
5 billion videos
it's the second biggest search engine
coming only after Google itself and the
YouTube app again as I said earlier is
one of the most popular apps in the
store
YouTube gives you qualified traffic
people on YouTube often have a question
they search for and if your video can
answer the question they have you will
get a qualified lead it's much like
Google search but then it's visual
also video content is 12 times more
likelier to be watched than text to read
video can evoke emotion they can make
you think they can make you feel and if
they make you think and feel you're not
likely to forget those videos and that's
much more that can be said for most
other types of online marketing
video also helped to humanize your brand
they bring it to life taking your
messages from flat and static to Dynamic
and engaging
videos help your brand build trust and
loyalty in a unique way
you can also use YouTube ads to reach an
even bigger audience YouTube advertising
runs on through the Google ads platform
and has some very powerful features and
more about these ads on YouTube later
videos can also be repurposed across
many other channels so they can help you
drive additional traffic to your website
you can share them on your social media
channels you can embed them on your own
website or you can include them in your
email marketing
to summarize video marketing is a must
for your business and if you're not on
the video train you will miss the next
stop
publishing regular videos is key and
YouTube offers you a YouTube channel as
your YouTube homepage for all your
videos
so here's a bit more background
information about a YouTube YouTube
ecosystem it's important to know that
there are three players in the YouTube
ecosystem
there's you the viewer there's the
content creator or the people that
upload their videos and there are Brands
Brands who want to reach you to sell
their products
and it's YouTube's challenge to keep
everybody happy in this ecosystem to
keep you happy to show you the best
videos keep content creators Happy by
enabling them to make some money and to
keep Brands Happy by connecting them
with the biggest audience possible
so how do Brands connect with you very
simple through advertising showing your
short video ads before or during the
videos you watch in fact 84 of YouTube
viewers both from Brands after watching
videos or ads they see on YouTube
and then how do content creators make
money very simple YouTube enables them
to earn ad revenue from ads that run
before or during their videos every time
an ad shows in front of the or during
the video they get a percentage of the
ad revenue and I'm sure you've seen
those ads while you were watching
YouTube videos
but not every YouTube content creator
qualifies for this you need to have at
least 1 000 subscribers to your channel
and a minimum of 4 000 watch hours on
your Channel
in other words
advertising in YouTube is the oil of the
YouTube ecosystem it keeps everybody
happy
and there are a variety of ads
marketeers can choose from many of them
find pre-roll skippable ads the most
effective you know those ads that you
can skip after a few seconds
just a little side note Here YouTube ads
on mobile are the most effective for the
simple reasons but many people watch
videos on their mobile but also many
peoples have ad blockers on their
desktop so your ads will not be seen on
their desktop
YouTube has recognized the power of
mobile video and mobile ads and has
announced that it will share 45 of AD
revenue on YouTube shorts
now what are YouTube Shorts YouTube
shorts are short vertical videos and
they are YouTube's response to the
phenomenal growth of tick tock and
vertical videos are key these days if
you want to boost engagement consider
using vertical videos
and here's why it has a 90 percent
higher completion rate compared to
Vertical videos
about 80 percent of consumers claim that
the format is more engaging and 65
percent of people find Brands using
vertical videos for their advertising to
be more innovative
so enough of the theory let's look at
the YouTube channels and look at what
you need and how to set up a unit your
YouTube channel
first of all you need a kit to make
videos whether it's your computer your
webcam a camera a smartphone and of
course you need a video editing software
and very important you need an indoor or
outdoor environment to make your videos
and then of course you need to make the
video this will be a topic for another
simply learned video in its own right
but here are a few tips
what make people watch videos
people watch videos when they are
educational
informational
entertaining funny controversial or
shocking
lots of examples in these categories of
videos in YouTube now what type of
videos do people like to watch there's a
whole range of different types of videos
but if you want to look at the most
popular ones you talk about unpacking
videos review videos Challenge videos
whole videos parodies covers live videos
how-to videos it's a whole range of
styles of video of topics or video that
you can create whether it's for Consumer
videos or for business videos
now what type of videos can you make
there's a whole range of different types
there's standard format video which is
horizontal there's the vertical video
which I talked about a little earlier
there are stop-motion videos
yeah there are time lapse videos you
could do 360 videos and the big growth
these days is in art is in augmented
reality and virtual reality
yep and then what do you need to think
about when you shoot your video there
are three very important aspects of
making your video think about light
think about sound and think about having
a stable camera position
your light is very important there's no
better light than outdoor light and if
you haven't got out if you don't shoot
outdoor but indoor make sure you have a
good lighting setup
sound can be very deceiving if you're
interviewing somebody on the video
outside you think there is no wind but
then when you hear the video back on
your computer you hear the wind it's
it's quite an interesting phenomenon but
it's effect so best is to have a high
quality microphone that you use when you
interview or when you record your videos
and think about a tripod as well make
sure your camera is in a stable position
so that's the theory behind all this
let's now look at some YouTube channels
and show you how to make a YouTube
channel and here is the simply learn
YouTube channel a very clear Channel
with lots of content for people to learn
about all topics in um in technology so
here you see the banner yeah with some
good messaging in there you have your
logo here you see the number of
subscribers yep so you see it's a
verified account by YouTube and here is
the Subscribe button yep and when you
are subscribed to a video or to a
channel the you get
um sort of personalized notifications or
you can switch off the notifications but
the beauty about people subscribe vibing
to your channel is that they will
receive a notification when you publish
a new video
then here you have a menu of things that
people can go to there's the home page
for all your videos there is a list of
all your videos you can organize your
videos in playlists you can look at the
comments that you're getting in the
community section you can set up
different channels and you can group
those channels under your account and
here is the about page where you have
about information about the company yep
and this is you can optimize this with
keywords so Google will Index this for
the for the search as well so let's look
at this home page again and the The
Branding yeah so here you see a feature
video
and there are two elements in this area
that are important here first of all you
saw just when I got on the page before I
subscribed you saw a different video yep
and then when you come back to the page
you can see another video so basically
you have a video that you can put here
for first-time visitors where you can
promote your company or your channel and
then you can have another video set up
for um returning visitors
and then here you have all your videos
and you can organize them in playlists
and in a minute I'm going to show you
how to set this all up and how to create
your own channel
okay so this is simply learn another
example would be one of my favorites on
social media is social media Examiner
here is the social media examiner
YouTube channel
yes so here you see the the featured
video here you see The Branding very
good branding with strong messages on
there an industry report that people can
download you see here you can put a few
links to your social media or your
website or where people can download for
instance the industry report here you
see The Branding the logo yeah again I
can subscribe to it and then here you
have the descriptions of the video and
the different channels the different
um playlists
okay so then here you have to group the
different channels that they have under
their um their their main channel the
social media Examiner
okay so you see coming back and I see
another video here so finally the other
one I want to show you is GoPro GoPro
they are very active on YouTube very
active on on having videos having videos
from their users from their subscribers
having very clear playlists
yes so
um and this could be um different
playlists from users the different
products features and what what have you
what you also see here is access to the
store
yeah where they sell products and if I
click on this I can then go to the GoPro
website where I can buy this this
product
so this is an overview of the YouTube
channel on the desktop but as we all
know most people and particularly the
younger generation they watch YouTube
videos on their mobile device so
whatever you do and in The Branding as
well on setting it up you need to make
sure that it looks well and it looks
good on the mobile as well so let's look
at these channels on the mobile device
yeah so here you see the mobile you see
exactly the same elements of it you see
your banner you see your uh your your
logo number of subscribers and your
feature video and then you have your
other videos
yeah so it's a lot easier to navigate
through one thing that you need to be
careful of is that the width of the
banner is not as white as the width on
the on the desktop yeah so in your
design you need to take that into
consideration otherwise half of this
text will be chopped off
yep so this is simply learn if we're
going to social media Examiner
yep so here is the social media examiner
page yeah their Channel again the the
banner and you have subscribed yep and
then here you see a different color yeah
with simply learn it was brownish here
it was greenish you cannot change this
color that is something that YouTube
will decide based on the overall color
it can pick it will pick up on your um
on your desktop on your uh on your
YouTube channel
okay so and again remember the banner
how white you go and then the other one
was the GoPro
yep here is the GoPro Channel
same look and feel here it is grayish
yeah with the banner the logo and then
the um the feature video
right time to have a look at how I
create a YouTube channel and how I
optimize it so I can grow my number of
subscribers to my channel
here you see the overall YouTube
interface and it's very important that
you get into YouTube and that you sign
in with your Google account
and once you have your Google account
set up and you're logged into your
Google account you can create a YouTube
channel
so how do you create a YouTube channel
here you see a your user yeah and here
you see your user icon and for me it's
just why I haven't put any visual there
yet yep and if you haven't done anything
on YouTube yet then this is the screen
that you will see yeah here you see the
videos that you can all access the
subscriptions how you can explore and
you can use YouTube without having
uploaded any video yourself or without
having created a channel
if you want to upload a video on YouTube
you click here on the plus
of course everything I'll show you you
can do on the mobile as well but my
experience if you are in admin mode and
you want to add text you want to add
your about you want to make different
selections then it's much easier to work
on the desktop so for demo purposes I'll
be showing it on the desktop okay so if
I click here on my user icon I get to
the menu of things I can do in my
account my Google account and my YouTube
account here you see create a channel
I can also go to YouTube studio and in
YouTube Studio I can edit all my videos
and optimize them I can check with
another I can switch to another account
I can look at my membership my data I
can look at the device theme I'm using
the language the restricted mode whether
you want a certain videos not to have
presented to you your location keyboard
shortcuts
Etc but what we're going to be looking
at is the create a channel
so I'll just click on create a channel
and here I'm going to add my name and my
name is basically I'm going to call it
Mark
tube yeah so my channel is called Mark
Cube I can upload my picture here I can
also do that at a later stage so let's
create the Channel first and then I'll
show you how to do The Branding so we'll
click on create channel
yep and then you will see that your
channel is ready so what I can do now of
course I can upload my first video I'm
not going to do that yet I'm going to go
straight into customize my channel and
then once my channel has been set up
I'll show you how to upload your first
video so here is customizing your
Channel
and there are three elements to it there
is the layout of your channel there is
The Branding of your channel and there
is the basic info of your Channel
yeah so let's look at the branding first
but before yeah remember we had the
video Spotlight which was your featured
video
so here you can specify which two videos
you want to have in the featured section
whether it is the video for people who
haven't subscribed and then the feature
video for the people who come back and
have subscribed and then here you have
your featured sections
remember you can have the videos you can
have different sections that you can add
here like popular uploads live past live
streams upcoming live stream the
playlists subscriptions feature channels
all in the menu that I showed you
earlier but we'll come back to that in a
little bit
yeah here is your menu on the left
which is also important yes so and we'll
come back to that in a minute as well so
first we're going to do is look at the
branding
yeah and here I can add my logo I can
add my banner image and I can add a
video Watermark which is standard watch
Mark that will show in all your videos
so very simple we're going to upload the
images so here you see my I've created
these in advance yeah so here you see my
YouTube logo
yep so very simple icon and I can now
select okay what section will I do I
want and make sure it fits within your
image area and you click done and you
have your icon your picture in setup
here you see the banner image you see at
least 2048 by 1152 pixels and six
megabytes or less if I click upload I
then have my banner image I click open
yeah and here remember what you see on
the desktop and what you see on the
mobile so here it is important that you
look at the text that you have on your
banner and make sure that it is viewable
on all devices I'm happy with this so I
click done
I'm not gonna do the watermark and then
I'm going to click publish
yep so the changes have been published
so if I'm now going to look at my
channel
view the channel on YouTube you now see
I have my banner I have my my banner
here I have my logo but of course
there's still a lot I have to do I have
to look at work on the about I have to
add maybe some other items in the menu
and of course I have to upload a video
so let's go back to the customize the
channel and what I'm going to look now
is to the basic info so first of all I
have my description so in the
description I'm going to tell people
what my channel is all about welcome
to my YouTube channel
a place
to learn everything
there is to know
about digital marketing
yeah and I can make this as big as
possible very I have a thousand
characters available and very important
thing keywords here yeah if you follow
digital marketing courses keywords are
the Cornerstone of your digital
marketing strategy I can add a language
and here I have my channel URL and I can
change this if I want to yeah so it's a
standard web address for your channel it
includes your unique Channel ID yeah but
you can change this as well
yeah so I can say here mark
no actually I cannot change this I will
be able I think to change this let's
have a look
customize customize URL is a shorter
easy to remember URL that you can share
with your audience and where you have
100 or more subscribers you have at
least 30 days old of your channel you
have uploaded your branding as well yeah
so to have
your number to have your customized URL
you need to have these 100 subscribers
and they have a channel that's at least
30 days old so I can't change this right
now and then here you can add the links
remember the links that you see on your
banner you can add a link
yeah so here I can say the link is Mark
kempman or let's say
simply learn
dot com and I can say https
simply
learn.com yeah and I can add a link I
can say
um Facebook
and I can say https
Facebook
.com forward slash simply learn and I'm
going to add Instagram
and I'm going to say https
instagram.com
forward slash simply learn
okay yep and then here I can say which
links do I want to show on the banner
yeah I can add a whole load of links
here but then I can say just show me the
first three links on the banner here's
the contact info that is marked at
simplylearn.com yep so here is my about
section ready and then here I can click
publish
and now I can go back to my channel
and what you see now my channel is ready
we have the banner we have the home uh
the logo and now here you see
simplylearn.com the website the Facebook
and the Instagram it will automatically
pick up the logos from the Facebook and
the Instagram and the other social
networks that you want to add here
all right so the next thing is that we
need to look here at the the topics that
we want here yeah we have Home Videos
playlists channels and about so I can
add multiple channels if I want but
let's go back to customizing
yes so we've done the layout we've done
we're going to look at the layout now
we've done The Branding we've done the
basic info so here is the channel
trailer we're going to do in a minute
when we've uploaded our first videos so
let's add a section and that would be
the created playlists
yep and we want to add a section let's
say uh popular uploads okay and then I
can say give me the created playlist I
want to the top
yeah I want the uploaded videos and then
I have the shorts and I have the popular
uploads okay and again I'm going to
click publish I'm going back to my
channel
yep so and now you won't see the order
yet because I haven't put in any any
videos of course but you will see as
soon as we start adding videos then you
will can you can see that we um that you
get the order that we've specified
Okay so
finally before we're going to upload the
video when we go into customizing your
channel you need to be aware here of the
features as well yeah the menu items
that you have so here is your channel
dashboard
so in your channel dashboard you see the
videos that you uploaded and it gives
you basic Channel Analytics
yeah and here you have some news from
YouTube about new features new training
Etc
here you see the content so here you see
a list of the videos that you've
uploaded their feasibility status is
there a restriction on the video what is
the date that you uploaded and you get
some basic analytics fuse comments and
likes
okay here are your playlists that you've
created
here you get your basic YouTube channel
Analytics
yeah you're looking at your comments
that you get so here you can sort of
um review the comments you can set some
moderation guidelines here you can also
add subtitles to your videos now we'll
go into that in more detail when we go
into YouTube and uploading videos and
how to optimize your YouTube videos
but Google will automatically subtitle
your videos and you can edit the um the
Subscribe the subtitles that Google will
will do yeah and very important to
remember if you use the Google
subtitles for your video it will not be
indexed for search for the simple reason
that there may be words that Google
misinterpreted in your video so you
always need to edit the video take the
typos the um the words that are
misunderstood by Google change those and
then as soon as you then change the
revised version of the subtitles Google
will then index the um the transcribed
file yeah for search
here is copyright information here is
monetization of your videos it's
important we talked about this earlier
yes so remember where you can have
advertising showing before or during
your videos and that is you will have to
become part of the YouTube Partner
program and once you're a member of the
partner program you'll be eligible to
earn money from your videos but you need
to have a minimum of 1 000 subscribers
and a minimum of 4 000 watch hours on
your videos
you need to set up two-step verification
and you need to agree to the community
guidelines
okay here is customization of your
channel yeah we sort of went through
this earlier and then here is a little
nugget in YouTube that not many people
are aware of and that is the audio
library YouTube holds a huge audio
library of tracks and sound files yeah
and sound effects that you can actually
download and add to your videos you can
search the library so it is a huge
library that you can add for free to add
to all your videos
and then finally there is the settings
of your channel so you can specify the
conversion or the currency for your
channel that you'll be using you can
specify the basic info of your channel
yeah you can have the country of
residence in my case we can set that on
the United Kingdom
yep and it can add keywords which is
digital marketing
yeah and I can say social
media and I can say YouTube
Etc
yep there is upload defaults so for
every video that you upload you can
specify a standard element in the title
standard element in the description the
visibility you can specify and public
private or unlisted so prior unlisted
means it will not show in the Google in
the YouTube search results
there is advanced settings that you can
say you can also in your video specify
chapters
and you can spend those chapters will
then be sort of summarized in the
description of your video and that will
be noted in the timeline of your video
as well so it's really good to structure
your videos
there's permissions yeah and this is
where you can invite other people to
make changes or to edit your channel
there is your community that's where you
can set moderation guidelines and then
there are agreements yeah there's the
subject to the the terms of service
okay so those are your settings so very
important that you understand this menu
right so our channel is ready however we
haven't got any video in our Channel yet
so let's go and add a video so here to
add a video we click Plus
okay and we're going to upload the video
or we can also go live
yeah so that's where we're going to do a
live broadcast or a live stream so
upload a video and here I'm going to
drag and drop a video or I can select a
file and here is my about us short
infographic
yep so here is the about us infographic
that is the title of course I can make
it as exciting as possible here I can
tell the uh short introduction
to our company
I can select a thumbnail of course I
have it hasn't selected the thumbnail
yet because it is still uploading and
optimizing the video yep you can then
say what playlist do you want it to be
part of what audience yeah there is an
automatic
catch filter is it made for kids or is
it not made for kids so it's like a
business type of theme yeah here is paid
promotion it's the pay promotion in the
video do you want automatic chapters
allow automatic places you can add text
this is all about optimizing your video
and that is for a different video that
we will be talking about how to optimize
your YouTube videos
okay and then it is going okay so that
is all done we're then clicking next
yeah I can say do I want subtitles do I
want to add an end screen do I want to
add cards remember you see that on
videos where at the end of the video you
see two cards where you can click on uh
to go to another video again I'm not
going to do that for this video and I'm
going to click next
yeah there is some copyright checks on
music and then we click next and here is
the video I can then save and publish I
want it to be public I can schedule the
publication yes so but this is all there
is to it and I'm gonna click publish
so I have now published my video I can
share it straight away on social media
again we're not going to do that I'm
just going to click close And now I see
my video in my content list
yeah I see a thumbnail I see the title I
can see the different details and if I
now go back to my channel
I can see my video in my channel but you
see here I have just put it as an upload
because I haven't added any playlists
yet
yeah so I need to go here to my
customize my channel
and I'm going to click first I'm going
to add the channel trailer and the video
I want to add to this is my about us
infographic and people that subscribed
I'm going to give them the same video
I am now going to add a playlist
so here are my playlists oh I first need
to
publish this
yeah there we go I'm now going to go to
my playlists and I'm going to create a
new playlist and that is sort of info
Graphics or let's say video graphics
all right and I'm gonna create my
playlists
okay so now I'm going back to my uh
content
and I'm now going to say go to edit this
video
yeah let's see if the playlists are here
go to the details thumbnail so here I
now in the video details I'm going to my
playlists and I'm going to select the
video graphics playlist done and I'm
going to click save
so now you see if I go back to my
channel
yeah so I'm back to my channel that my
channel now looks slightly different
foreign
I have my presentation my featured
videos
okay and I have my playlists
and I have my uploads
yep so this is how you can build your
channel how you can optimize your
channel add videos to your channel add
playlist to your channel so
I hope that was a um was a simple uh yet
effective overview for you how to set up
your Channel
so
that is it on the channel so let's
finish today's video with giving you
some tips on how to promote your YouTube
channel
it is very important that you promote
your channel for the simple reason you
want to get
subscribers
yep remember your YouTube channel is
your so your YouTube social media
Network it is where you can develop your
brand it is where you can get people
excited it is where you can build
relationships with people who watch your
videos so it's very important that you
do everything that's possible to promote
your uh your YouTube channel so how do
you go about promoting it first of all
very important in video marketing is the
title of your video
yeah you see here the about us
infographics you see that is the title
of this video is pretty boring if you
look at most titles of videos on YouTube
yeah let's see let's say if I search on
YouTube for let's say social media you
immediately see the titles that are
powerful how social media rewires your
brain is social media hurting your
mental health
yeah like selfies and self-promotion the
hidden dangers of social media
five crazy ways social media is changing
your brain right away
yeah you're a bit more neutral but still
powerful how to develop a social media
strategy step by step these are the type
of things that people like to uh to
watch because those titles are very
engaging
you know hand in hand with the title is
also the thumbnail that you're using for
your videos
yeah so here you see a good example 365
days of journaling that's the thumbnail
that they they use yeah if you go to
social media examiner you see good
examples of thumbnails
yeah and they are all they have the same
color style they have the same bold text
bold titles they still show people yeah
so these are very powerful
thumbnails for your video and look at
yourself if you're doing a search on
YouTube yeah what videos will you most
likely watch videos where you like the
title and videos where you like the
thumbnail when they spring out when they
scream out of the search results
okay so very important that you um that
you look at that
okay next thing how do you optimize your
channel is by making sure that your
videos are optimized
yeah so if I go to my videos your videos
and then here you have your video and I
go to edit the details
I can edit the title the description
remember keywords I can edit the
thumbnail I can edit tags yeah I can
edit
um language lots of stuff that you can
optimize about your videos another
important
factor is make videos that your audience
wants to see
understand your audience yeah in digital
marketing terms we advise our clients to
make customer personas
and customer personas you specify their
pains their needs and everything that
is important for them when they buy your
your product yes so by understanding
what your audience wants you then can
tailor the content of your videos
to their requirements
the next important aspect of your
YouTube channel is engaging with the
community
it has very important that when people
start adding comments in your videos
that you engage with them
yeah that is one place where you sort of
build your your community you engage
with people but you also engage with
YouTubers in your Market
associated with your Market yeah comment
on other people's videos so start
engaging with other content creators in
building your online YouTube reputation
as it were and start sharing your videos
yeah with them so that is an important
one another important aspect of your
channel is that you need to cross
promote your own videos within your
videos yeah so it's very common if I go
to Simply learn yeah and go to their
Channel and I'm sure they have it on one
of their videos if I go to let's say
here
data analytics
yes so it's a long course but if I go to
the end of the video
I'm sure you see that here at the end
yeah so you see here at the end the next
video that they promote so you cross
promote your other videos within your
video that you're showing it's a very
powerful aspect of
um the growing your YouTube channel
cross-promoting your video
yet another one is very powerful it's
what we call video series
yeah they are very good in driving
traffic to your channel yeah why because
people want to if they like it they will
come back for the second episode
or if they jump in for instance for the
first time in the fourth episode if they
see the episode if they like the episode
then they say hey I want to watch
episode one two and three as well so
very important is to create series of
videos a good example is social media
Examiner
yeah when you go to the social media
examiner YouTube page and you go to the
playlists here you see the journey
and the journey is a uh basically a
series of videos
of the history of the company yeah so
you see episode one episode two episode
three yeah they even have multiple
Seasons yeah of this and this was very
successful in their their marketing
promotion yeah so create YouTube series
okay so back to my channel another way
of promoting your channel and promoting
your videos is to make sure that your
videos are outside YouTube as well so if
I click on the video yeah and I click
share instead of just sharing the code
here yeah the the URL I'm actually going
to take the embed code so the embed code
gives you an iframe which will actually
show the video on your website if you
add this iframe code to your web page
yeah and people will watch can watch the
video on your um your website but it
will count as a few on on YouTube
yep and then when people click on
Youtube it'll take them to your channel
where they can
um where they can subscribe to your
Channel
yeah we talked about playlists very
important to promote your Channel
yeah the playlists are important and
make sure you add calls to action to
your video at the end of the video get
people to do something to buy something
or to sign up or to register for an
event going live always works in
promoting your Channel
yeah doing live broadcast live behind
the scenes when you're at an event new
live broadcasts really good way to
promote your channel you can promote the
event you can announce the event it will
lead to buzz before the broadcast during
the broadcast and after the broadcast
yeah we talked about collaboration with
other creators with other brands and
then of course Very powerful you can
actually promote your own ads by
advertising yes so I can go to Google
ads I can create a video ad and add a
video ad is my short video and then that
video will show before and during
um videos that people watch
yep and that will drive views on your
videos and Views obviously will turn
into subscriptions to your channel as
well
and then last but not least of course is
publishing your videos and your YouTube
content on social media channels as well
yeah Twitter of course is a very obvious
place to promote your videos but use it
on on other social channels as well now
Facebook doesn't necessarily like it
when you link to the YouTube video
because Facebook wants you to upload the
whole video yes so then people will stay
within YouTube within Facebook to watch
the video but there are other social
media channels where you can promote
your videos as well
okay well that concludes the session
on your YouTube channels
I hope you liked this yeah so remember a
YouTube channel is your social media
Network for your videos on Google and on
YouTube
yep and it gives you a fantastic tool to
widen your reach to reach a global
audience and to start building
relationships with your subscribers yep
and help them in the process of
familiarizing themselves with your
products or your services ultimately
leading to them in buying your product
of your service YouTube ideas for 2021
YouTube is the social media platform
that needs new introduction launched
back in the Year 2005 YouTube was a
fresh breath of air for the people who
were slowly becoming aware of the hype
that surrounded the internet several
other platforms like Dailymotion redmi
and VMO which admittedly have their own
fans have tried to stand up against the
wehemoth that is the YouTube and failed
slowly but surely marketers began to
realize the enormous potential that
YouTube offered they could add small
advertisements like they do in the cable
TV they could show banner ads and do
much more and all the thanks to the
robust advertisement features that
Google already offered if you're not
already sold on why it's important to
advertise on YouTube here are some facts
that might change your mind YouTube has
more than 2 billion users across the
world I've got fraction of that audience
could be shown your product and could
turn from users to customers next
important fact is that 8 out of 10
marketers consider YouTube to be one of
the best platforms to advertise their
products and services followed by that
people watch one billionaires of YouTube
per day as you watch this video you are
contributing to that number
next 62 percent of the business use
YouTube to post content this could be
just videos on their products tutorials
event announcements and much more
seventy percent of the YouTube watch
time comes from mobile this means that
when you create an advertisement for
YouTube you keep the mobile users in
your mind and finally 90 percent of the
people say that they've discovered new
products or brands on YouTube which
means that by posting on YouTube your
brand awareness is highly likely to
increase now let's talk about the video
ideas
the first one is behind the scene videos
these videos give you the opportunity to
showcase your audience how your business
or brand operates a creatively made
video on the inner workings of your
business will show off a more human side
of your brand and make you more
relatable to your audience it is also
guaranteed to get you loads of views and
engagement here's an example how Amazon
showcases the warehousing and
distribution aspects of its products it
takes the viewers into the factories and
involves the various people working
there this shows to the audience that
even a large organization like Amazon
how each individual has an important
role to play in the overall process
next we have the company culture a video
that highlights your company culture
will tell the audience what your
business goals are what its values are
and why it exists it can also focus on
the various people who make sure the
company works in the way it does this
can help better connect with your
audience here's an example a company
culture video created by GoDaddy the
popular domain register
the video talks about how GoDaddy
creates a fun inclusive and energetic
environment for its employees it
includes interviews of employees talking
about why they enjoy working in GoDaddy
so much and this helps the audience
relate with the company and could also
catch up the interest with some
potential job Seekers next we have the
third idea that is the marketing team a
brand is nothing without the people
working behind it and that's where these
videos come in these videos will help
shine a light on the people who create
the products that the audience knows and
loves this helps create a personal
connection with the audience these
individuals can end up becoming mascots
for your brand here's an example of Meet
the team focusing on Olympus group the
video goes into the history of masket
makers brand and the people that make it
a grand success the light-hearted tone
of the video also greatly helps with
making it more relatable now we have
number four product showcase or
announcement
a product Showcase Video aims to show
the features and benefits of the Brand's
latest offering to its audience these
short concise videos can inform the
audience about everything they need to
know about the new product or service a
product announcement video on the other
hand can be used to give the audience a
more detailed look into the product or
service than the product showcase
it can include comparisons to older
versions or competitors the aim of such
video is to show customers how the new
product works and why they need it
now this video needs no introduction
Apple's iPhone videos have always been
short but smooth sleek and concise
representations of what the product
would be like
next at number 5 we have event
announcements these videos can build a
hype regarding an upcoming event it will
also give you the opportunity to engage
with your audience and build their
interest
this promo video for the data Innovation
Summit 2020 Hypes up the event posting
the greatest Minds in the tech the most
Innovative companies and much more
the next video idea we have at number
six is the explainer videos these videos
are aimed to tell users how a particular
product or a service works these tend to
be much more useful than wall of text
explaining how something works they also
have an added advantage of simplifying
complex Concepts and features to your
audience for example we have our own
video on digital marketing we cover a
number of different concepts like SEO
social media marketing search engine
marketing and more on a visual Mana
making it more likely to grab the
attention of a viewer
next at number seven we have tutorials
tutorial videos give users some
actionable insights and knowledge that
your users can learn from these videos
aim to be guides to information complex
Concepts hints tips and tricks relating
to your industry here we have our own
digital marketing course video as an
example unlike the previous example I
mentioned this video goes into much more
detail regarding each of the concepts of
digital marketing on that note if you
guys are interested in learning about
digital marketing I suggest you start
from this video it's a great one to get
started with now on the next video idea
at number eight we have the product
tutorial a product tutorial video will
take your audience through the various
features of your product offers
alongside its intricacies it can also
detail some additional insights about
your product you can also explain the
best way the product can be used
here's a video of how the meditation app
headspace explains the app's usage with
an interesting and creative animated
video
now let's go ahead with number nine at
the number nine we have the webinar a
webinar thanks to its nature provides
your brand with loads of opportunities
to interact with your audience they are
usually very accessible and easy to make
they are also very cost effective and
can be reused as video content after the
session is complete here's an example of
Simply learns webinar where we talk to
the industry experts regarding wide
variety of topics while involving the
Audience by having the guest answer the
audience questions whenever possible
next at number 10 we have the live
streams live streams for an event will
help build excitement and hype for the
event it can be advertised on other
social media platforms to generate some
hype as well these videos can also help
you bring up your product to a larger
audience and at a reduced cost
here's an example of a live stream that
constantly keeps a track of subscribers
increasing for some of the most popular
YouTube channels next at number 11 we
have Ama or ask me anything sessions
the AMA or ask me anything sessions are
usually live streams or pre-recorded
sessions that feature questions
collected from the audience although it
originated from Reddit these videos are
finding a success on YouTube thanks to
the interactivity that it offers these
sessions can also give your audience the
opportunity to interact with you provide
suggestions feedback and much more
here's an example of AMA session where
the actor Matt Damon where questions
covering a wide variety of topics
collected from Reddit were answered by
him
next at number 12 we have interviews
interviewing someone interesting or of
an authority within your Niche can go a
long way to grow your audience these
sessions are doubly advantageous too
firstly you and by extension your
audience get to interact with an
industry style world and since this
video can be shared on your channel as
well as theirs you can expose your
channel to a brand new audience here's
an example of an interview between
Marcus Brownlee a popular Tech YouTuber
with Bill Gates the interview covers a
wide variety of topics and maintains a
pleasant theme throughout let's now go
to number 13 testimonials a testimonial
video help highlight the positive
feedback from a client or a customer
they provide social proof and provide a
unique perspective on your products and
services these videos can greatly help
improve people's trust on your brand
shareability and credibility here's an
example of Simply lunch testimonial
video that covers a learner's Journey as
he crew in his career video thanks to
Simply learn certification a video like
this can be greatly relatable to the
audience and even encourage some of them
to take up a certification let's go to
our next video idea that is the number
14 whiteboard videos a whiteboard video
offers your visually attractive way of
explaining complex Concepts usually this
involves a trained experts breaking
through a complex topic on a whiteboard
nowadays there has also been the trend
of digital whiteboard videos that work
thanks to the visual style and Charisma
of the narrator here is an example of
the Whiteboard video Simply learn
created covering various concepts of
social media marketing with the help of
an engaging narrative and interesting
visuals next up we have number 15
competitions competitions or contest
videos give your audience the
opportunity to get involved with your
channel these videos enable you to
generate fresh and original content with
little from your end
in an interesting example for foldable
flight Channel users submitted their
ideas for paper airplanes that would go
to the farthest distance the channel
received a significant amount of
submissions and saw considerable growth
next we have 16 the lists list videos
are some of the most commonly found
content on YouTube most users enjoy this
type of content thanks to it being small
easily digestible and bite-sized
these videos can cover a wide range of
topics like options to choose from the
best products techniques and much more
the main advantage of these videos are
the provide users with value while
further involving them with your channel
here's an example of a list that we have
created on the top 10 skills you need to
become a data analyst in the year 2021
if you are interested don't forget to
check it out at number 17 we have case
studies case studies talk about how your
product or service have benefited
clients and users
videos like this can greatly improve
relatability and making your brand seem
more likeable
here's a video that analyzes Coca-Cola's
marketing campaign and what it made one
of the most popular brands in the world
now let's talk about content that may
not be necessarily for a brand but for
individual creators at number 18 we have
Tech unboxing these videos usually
involve packages being open for the
first time while these are fairly common
for technology these videos have also
found success in fashion apparel these
videos enable the users to experience
the products for the first time
sometimes even helping them decide
between rival products here's an example
of PS5 being inboxed by Marcus Brownlee
who goes into detail regarding each of
its console components controllers and
other specifications at number 19 we
have tech reviews where tech reviews you
can talk about the various features of a
particular product what you liked about
it what you didn't its price and other
practical information and much more
here we have an example of OnePlus 8 Pro
being reviewed in detail covering its
many features advantages disadvantages
and much more and finally we have number
20 reaction videos reaction videos are
exactly what the name says you giving an
emotional reaction to something like a
movie trailer music video or TV episode
these videos encourage a large amount of
Engagement from the audience and make
your brand seem more relatable here's an
example of a reaction video involving
teenagers reacting to the latest tech
talk videos these videos usually enable
a large amount of likes comments and
shares keyword research so basically
what we want to do is Center our
keywords just like our website we want
to Center our keywords around or our
content around good keywords so the
videos on YouTube are no different than
the web pages on our website so if we
have somebody who states YouTube is the
world's second most well well-known
engine well it is because it's right
behind Google it's not a search engine
per se it's a video platform but if it
was a search engine it'd probably be
second right behind Google so YouTube is
pretty popular majority people use
YouTube search every day to watch videos
on a number of different topics so they
can find these videos in Google but
because YouTube's so powerful and so
popular people go directly right into
YouTube for their searches and so the
whole idea behind YouTube being the
second most well-known search engine is
centered around keywords so if you have
the right keywords for your video then
the chances of you ranking higher
increases on YouTube so we're gonna
share with you a few easy ways to do
keyword research this is the most
important step in getting your videos to
rank on YouTube just like for those of
you who watched any of the SEO videos we
produced it simply learn you know that
keyword research is so essential to
getting your web pages to rank on Google
well it's no different keyword research
and choosing the right keywords is just
as important for your videos as is for
your web pages so we're going to go into
a few things to do here to find the
right keywords so we have the search
suggestion you can look at your
competitors we have different tools we
can use some other factors involved in
Google itself so let's start talking
about some of these ways to really hone
in and do some good research on your
keywords to align them with your videos
first thing is search suggest so YouTube
has a feature called autocomplete so if
you've done any searches on Google it's
very similar if you're typing something
in to YouTube search then YouTube is
going to suggest other related popular
keywords so let's take a look at that if
we go back to YouTube for a second and I
just type in machine learning YouTube is
going to populate on the autocomplete in
the search bar some other popular
keywords that we can potentially use or
in this case if I Choose You Know
machine learning tutorial I'm going to
see a video about machine learning
tutorial so here you can see simply
learns ranked number one for machine
learning tutorial but there are other
videos that show up in my search result
so we want to be able to use the search
suggestion box in the search box field
so when we're typing in something new
YouTube just like on Google is going to
give us those suggestions so if we're
focusing a video on machine learning
then you know we have some ideas of some
other keywords that we could center
around because these are are popular
keywords these are key words that people
are using to search on YouTube so that's
one suggestion looking at competitors is
another suggestion so we could search
for keywords used by our competitors in
their video and title and description so
let me talk a a little bit about that
what you want to do is you want to go to
that particular channel of your
competitor so when you go to your
particular competitors YouTube channel
you want to be able to click on the
videos tab when you click on the videos
tab then you're going to sort by most
popular and then what you could do is
see a list of videos and then when you
look at a list of videos you're going to
choose a video and then what you're
going to do then is take a look at the
keywords used in the title and
description and then once you do that
you're going to have a list of keywords
that you can use yourself for that video
so for example let's go back to YouTube
so if I go to type in simply learn
here's our Channel page just by clicking
on simply learn I click on videos ever
wonder if there's so now I can see all
the videos ever wonder if there's an
easier way go back so here I can see all
the videos sort by most popular once
they do that then I can choose a video
this is the most popular video right now
for simply learn if I click on that
video it's automatically going to start
playing but what I could do is simply
just look at you know the content
description so just by clicking show
more I can see all the content that
align with this video that's one way to
do it is simply by looking at your
competitors now what you could also do
is look at the tags associated with the
particular video and so what you want to
do is you want to look at the HTML and
so that means looking at the page source
so just like web pages what YouTube does
is they look at meta tags so if you call
from SEO in order to get your pages to
rank you need to have a title tag and a
meta tag description so videos are no
different what we're doing for YouTube
is aligning certain keywords with the
video so if you take a look and do a
search for keywords by viewing the page
Source you're going to see all the
keywords associated with a particular
video so so for example if I go back to
YouTube and I look at the page source of
a video Let's just say this video here
Facebook's ad tutorial I'm going to pull
up the page source and all I need to do
is control F and type in keywords and
now for that Facebook video I can see
all the keywords associated with the
video so you can see there's a lot of
different keywords we're aligning with
this video and so why do we want to do
that because we want you know our video
to show up for keywords that people may
type in and so if you use that YouTube
autocomplete it's going to give you
those ideas this most popular keywords
so if they're related align those
keywords with the video so here you can
see Facebook marketing Facebook ad
strategy Facebook ads for beginners so
forth and so on so there's a lot of
keywords we've aligned here with that
particular video and again all you need
to do is look at the page source so
right clicking view page Source do a
control F for keywords and and you'll be
able to see the keywords aligned so you
could do that for your competitors
videos as well so you could see what
keywords your competitors using for a
video that's most popular for their
Channel and is also ranking on YouTube
and on Google so using the autocomplete
gives you those keyword ideas looking at
your competitors videos also gives you
some other ideas for keywords that you
can align with a video that's relevant
that you want to rank for so let's look
at some other ideas here so you can
install plugins and there are plenty of
plugins available on the Chrome browser
that will help you see the video tags
associated with a particular video so a
couple of examples or vid IQ and
tubebuddy those are extensions that work
in Chrome and what they do is they give
you the exact tags that a particular
video is using so for example if I go
back here and I look at a video on
YouTube let's just say the machine learn
learning Basics video I have vid IQ
installed on my Chrome browser so just
by clicking on that vid IQ is going to
give me a lot of information about that
video you're just going to give me an
overview of their particular metrics
they're going to give me some other
information associated with Facebook
some engagement metrics really what I'm
interested in is those keywords so if I
scroll down a bit here I can see the
video tags associated with the machine
learning Basics video so vid IQ is
telling me is these keywords are
associated with this video and not only
does it show me what keywords are
associated I can also see where they
rank so for machine learning Basics this
particular video ranks number one if I
go down I could see what is machine
learning and how does it work I can see
it's rank number two here I could see
machine learning algorithms it's ranked
number nine so I can get some ideas of
the types of keywords that are being
used as tags for that video further down
I can also see some Channel tags but
really this is the video tags or the
idea place I want to be able to look to
get an idea of the types of keywords
that are associated with the video that
are also ranking or not ranking so
that's another way for you to really get
an understanding of what keywords to use
at the particular video so autocomplete
you can look at the page source of a
competitors video or you can use a
Chrome extension in this case I'm using
vid IQ to give me some information about
the video tags for a particular video so
according to an industry study using
keywords and video tags will help you
rank well on YouTube so you have to use
keywords and video tags if you want your
video to rank there's been a lot of
studies YouTube is so popular and videos
are so prominent in today's world where
if you have videos and you're going to
upload them to YouTube then associate
the right keywords with those videos so
some important factors when we look at
keywords what we want to do is look at
search volume we want to look at
competition we want to look at relevancy
we want to look at the primary and
secondary keywords that we want to use
so well chosen keywords will help you
rank so we just gave you some ideas on
how to do some keyword research again
those ideas were really to use the
autocomplete on YouTube or Google
they're going to give you some popular
keywords you can look what your
competitors are doing by looking at the
page source and just looking at the
keywords that are aligned with that
video or you can use a third-party
extension in Chrome in my example I use
vid IQ that gave me the keywords
associated with that video so you have
ways to get the keywords so what we want
to do is we want to make sure we choose
keywords with high search volume they're
going to drive more traffic to your
video however we want to balance it out
with key keywords that have low
difficulty and are easier to rank for so
you don't want to choose something very
broad that's just going to be very
difficult to rank for and of course we
always want to go with relevancy so for
talking about machine learning Basics
then we want to choose keywords
associated with that and that's where
that autocomplete comes in handy because
what Google's going to do and YouTube's
going to do is give us keywords that are
very closely related to the video that
we're trying to optimize for and so we
have a number of different keywords at
our disposal that are relevant that we
can look to see if they have good volume
and low competition and so the whole
idea is we want to choose a keyword that
defines the nature of the content and
then what we want to do is support that
with secondary keywords so we want
keywords that are highly relevant to the
primary keyword so that's the way to go
about aligning your keywords you want
keywords that are high volume low
competition or relevant and you want to
choose that one keyword that is really
what the content's about and then
there's secondary keywords that support
the primary so if you have a machine
learning video you could choose your
primary keyword as in this case the
machine learning Basics video so well
chosen keywords help you rank well on
YouTube just like the machine learning
Basics so if I go back to our video our
machine learning Basics video if I just
type in machine learning Basics I'll be
able to pull it up and so here it is if
I click on it I'm going to go to YouTube
and so here I can see this keyword we
know humans learn from is well aligned
because it's in the title it's in the
copy and it's a line is a keyword tagged
with the video so we know that that
keyword has good volume low competition
is relevant because that's what the
video is about the basics of machine
learning it's an introduction to machine
learning so instead of honing in on just
introduction and machine learning
primary keyword is machine learning
Basics and then we supported that video
with those secondary keywords what is
machine learning because somebody who
doesn't know machine learning is
probably going to type in that keyword
and then introduction to machine
learning is a good secondary keyword
because it's explaining the basics of
what machine learning is all about so
primary keyword machine learning basic
secondary keywords what is machine
learning and introduction to machine
learning so that's the whole idea behind
choosing keywords you want that keyword
that really is going to define the
content and then support that with those
secondary keywords so remember when
you're performing your keyword research
choose keywords for your videos that
Google shows on the video results page
so what I mean by that is your video can
get more views if you rank on Google as
well so the whole idea is not
necessarily to be found on YouTube it's
also to be found on Google so if I go
back to Google and I just type in data
science for beginners and I type in
videos then you can see we're ranked
number one so even if you're not looking
at the videos clicking on the videos
link on Google search you can always
just when you do a search what Google's
going to do is also put in the videos
here on par as part of the search
results so what they're going to show
you is the top videos that are ranking
for that particular keyword and so we
may not rank overall for data science
for beginners but we're ranked number
one in the videos category and so if
somebody's looking for a video that's
important and you can see here that
these first two are ads so what Google
is doing is they're saying hey this is
so relevant this particular video for
the keyword query data science for
beginners that we're going to show it
above the organic listings even though
it's a video so the whole idea is to be
found on YouTube and Google because
you're increasing your visibility you're
increasing your chances of getting found
on both search platforms so according to
backlinko google Ranks videos with
keywords like how to tutorials so you
know a lot of the videos that you find
on YouTube are going to be instructional
based and so what Google's doing is
they're saying hey if somebody types in
how to or tutorial or an introduction to
anything that's going to signal to
Google that it's instructional it's
going to help you rank so when you
search for machine learning tutorial or
how to become a machine learning
engineer you're going to get results
related to that because if you look at
these examples we have machine learning
tutorial in our title or how to become a
machine learning engineer so keep that
in mind if you're creating a video and
it's educational in nature you know use
those key terms like how to and
tutorials in the video title because
that will help you rank so let's move
over now to video title so we want to
use our Target keyword in the title of
the video and again we want to make sure
if it's education additional to include
that keyword tutorial or how to so for
every video title YouTube has a limit of
100 characters so we really have to pick
and choose really wisely so if we look
at the video that we were focusing on a
couple of minutes ago so machine
learning Basics here we could see under
100 characters we have machine learning
Basics what is machine learning
introduction to machine learning and
then the brand name so that is the title
of this particular video so it takes
into account the primary keyword the
secondary keywords and the title and it
also includes that really that key term
that really Google and YouTube like and
that's what is machine learning so it's
helping us Rank by having our keywords
in the title with that key phrase what
is okay so that's a good tidbit on
creating a good video title is to align
it with the right keywords your primary
and your secondary and so we want to use
the those catchy words and numbers to
gain High click-through rates just like
you would on the title tag of your web
page we want to do the same with our
video title because the video titles
what's going to show up in search so if
I go back to you know search here we
could see you know data science tutorial
data science for beginners so we want to
make sure in this case you can see data
science in five minutes so that was
purposely done so that hey I don't have
time to watch a video I only have a
couple minutes data science in five
minutes okay great I'm going to click on
the video and now I have an opportunity
to watch something and learn something
under five minutes so choosing the right
words in your video title is going to
help you get that click-through rate up
remember click the array is clicks
divided by Impressions and an impression
is how many times your video shows up
and the search results on YouTube or
Google so we want to keep our
click-through rate high and in order to
do that we want to be able to write some
really good title tags for our video so
use catchy words like a number or how to
or what is because that's going to
resonate with people when they're
searching now for the description what
we want to do is we want to use the
target word at the beginning of the
description the title and the tags
itself so if I go back to my video here
machine learning Basics we know it's in
the video title and right off the bat if
I look at the description of the video
here I can see this machine learning
Basics video will help you understand
what is machine learning so our primary
keyword is in the first sentence right
in the introductory of the description
and so that's going to bode well for
optimizing our video the description
length is 5 000 characters so we have a
lot of characters to work with so if I
go back to my video I click show more we
have a lot of characters to really
describe what the video is about okay
there's no shortage no shortage of
including keywords into the content so
you have 5 000 characters go ahead and
see if you can work in naturally your
keywords but one of the key tips here is
just make sure that first sentence
starts out with that keyword that's a
good tip of course you always want to
make it sound natural as possible you
don't want to stuff it with keywords at
the same time work them in naturally
work in your keywords naturally and then
include hashtags in your description to
help the audience find your video is
easily so if I go back here you know we
want to be able to include hashtags so
hashtags it's like anything else you
would use on social media it just
signals to the end user hey this is what
the video is all about and if I go ahead
and type in that keyword then it's our
video has a better chance because it's a
line with that hashtag and then there's
Target keywords and LSI keywords latent
semantic indexing keywords we want to be
able to use those keywords as Target
keywords with our video so if you recall
the example I gave a few minutes ago we
used the Facebook ads tutorial as our
example here I could see all the target
keywords associated with that particular
video so don't be afraid to use those
LSI related keywords meaning keywords
that are related to the content use them
as Target keywords with the video so
between your LSI keywords Target
keywords and then using our primary and
secondary keyword in the title tag using
our primary and secondary keyword in the
description and then using hashtags in
the description the combination of all
of that if we chose the right keyword
then we should find that our video will
eventually rank on YouTube so just doing
these small tidbits with our keywords
really help get our video to rank so at
the end of the day we want to be able to
use the tools available to Us YouTube
Itself by looking at our competitors
those extensions like vid IQ the
autocomplete to really find our good
keywords and then incorporating those
keywords into you know the title tag the
description as Target keywords hashtags
we should really be off and running with
our video on YouTube
[Music]
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learned YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here